I'd like to go ahead and start today's
work
um
this is the education committee for the
house and we today we have three bills
dealing and this particular meeting
right here dealing with mental health in
our schools and we have another one
starting up this afternoon at one
o'clock dealing with uh financing
special education
so uh prior to our getting into
uh some notices for the the committee
here I do want to introduce a person
that's going to be critical and
important to our committee here Karen
Karen Davis is standing over by the door
she started yesterday she will be our
Administrative Assistant uh you remember
we had Lindsay
and then prior to Lindsay we had Judy
and but that now we're dating back
14 years so so Karen
uh Karen has been working uh she started
work yesterday so she's kind of like OJT
still uh and but we want to welcome you
Karen and we look forward to working
with you
and pardon me
well she's taking Lindsay's position and
you know Lindsay also had a number of
other committees I don't think there's
been a whole lot Karen what committees
are you assigned to
kitchen
yeah
and so as you can see she's got biggies
and so there's going to be a lot of
demand coming her way so anything we can
do to help her out uh I'd appreciate and
I'm sure sure Karen would too why don't
we go around the table quickly and
introduce yourselves just by name and
starting down there representative
Balboni and and working our way around
so that Karen will know we are committee
members and many of us will oftentimes
pop down say hey can I get a copy of a
certain bill or Etc
hi Peggy Balboa representing Rockingham
838 which is Northampton Greenland and
rye
representative Karine cascadden
representing co-as District Five city of
Berlin
representative Valerie McDonald
representing Rockingham District 25
which is Salem
representative Katie pedernal
representing Carroll District Six which
is toughton bro and wolf bro
Patty Cornell Manchester Ward 11.
Linda Tanner Sullivan five Sunapee and
Springfield
Dave luno Hopkinton and Beau
I'm now Miler Hopkinton and Beau
Glenn cordelli representing Tuftonboro
Wolfeboro and Ossipee
Rick Ladd representative from Haverhill
Piermont Warren landaf
welcome
Arlene cortiello from Atkinson
Rockingham 18.
Kristen Noble and I represent Bedford
Memorial Hall representing Beau in
Hopkinton welcome
good morning hope Damon Sullivan
District 8 Acworth Langdon lemster
Goshen Washington Springfield Sunapee
Croydon where I live in Claremont
you got them all
yeah
okay uh our Ellison uh Merrimack 28 I
represent Awards one two and three here
in Concord
Richard Sullivan District Seven I live
in Plainfield and represent also Cornish
Charlestown unity and Newport
good morning again rep Mike Belcher
Carroll District 4 out of Wakefield
Alicia leckis
Hillsboro 38 Hudson and Litchfield
well there you have it Karen
representative woodcock's not here and
representative Ford's not here but we
will give you a test a little later on
to know the names and to know all those
towns each of us represents good luck so
have a wonderful day and thank you again
okay for the committee I want to give
you some dates that we have coming up
that you won't see in the calendar just
yet they will be submitted this
Wednesday so you'll get the heads up I
know folks are really trying to schedule
a lot of things such as doctors
appointments visiting with grandkids
babysitting whatever it might be all
important so let me go down through some
of the bills of course we have today 352
505 151 all dealing with mental health
we will have a follow-up meeting to this
on October 12th at one o'clock
now these are work work study groups we
don't we're not taking action during a
work study group all the action on our
committee work whether it be a committee
the whole or a separate subcommittee
will be done later in November too
approximately that and that's not a
solid date yet but we have to have
everything out by the 17th I believe
so we'll be taking action on all these
retained bills all 20 of them in
November going on down we also have 354.
that's the bill which we've been dealing
with Charter School building Aid and and
studying overall building AIDS uh for
the state that will be next the next
meeting for that will be scheduled on
October 6th at 10 o'clock
so that's 354 October 6th at 10 o'clock
going on down
to other meetings also scheduled on
October 6. and these are all committee
the whole type meetings so we will all
be able to come in and we'll just go
through these types of bills one after
another saving some time for travel on
you 147 HB 147 will be also on October
6th at 10 o'clock we'll just list them
all and we'll just take them as we go
right through like we are exactly but we
won't be exacting we'll be just studying
um 155 Surety identification private
post secondary schools that's also
scheduled for October 6th at 10 o'clock
HB 439
also October 6th uh that deals with uh
duty to provide education and contracts
with privates uh that's uh at 10 o'clock
on October 6th going on down further we
have another one HB 627 local Education
Agency Improvement plans and disparities
in education that will also be on
October 6th at 10 o'clock
and lastly on October 6 at 10 o'clock uh
SB 25 Charter School payments
so on October 6 we will have one two
three four five six bills uh to be
scheduled there
going on down there's one other meeting
which we have I spoke at when we met
last I think it was last week when we
talked about the Ed 306 rules that will
be on October 12th at 10 o'clock that's
where we have Fred bramonte the ex-ch
chair of the State Board of Education
coming in presenting the Draft rules for
306 the minimum standards for public
school approval that will be on October
12th at 10 o'clock
so on October 12th at 10 o'clock we will
have those rules in the morning and then
in the afternoon we'll follow up with
meetings following up on where we are
today
any questions
yes representative Cornell is the
presentation by Barbara Monte going to
be different than the presentations that
he's going around the state doing I hope
it's different okay uh because I've done
that we we I did it too I did it at
Concord High School but uh there was a
lot that he mentioned in fact it was
really when he was at Concord High
School he spoke to the draft proposal
but there wasn't enough time to get into
a thorough discussion on specific points
and there's a lot of different things
comp disease Mastery of this and the
elements within the subject areas in 306
that we didn't get into a discussion at
all and which we need to do and there's
other areas as well so yes
representative like us
wouldn't that be also live
for those of us who are out of state to
be able to watch it and maybe text some
questions to somebody to ask it they it
will be at committee Hall we we can have
that happen that's everything else
happens like that that doesn't seem to
be a problem to me okay good so you
could you know tap in that way but I
think it's a good idea if if uh Fred
bermont is going to be here that we try
to make an effort to be here and follow
up on each other's questions and delve
into a dive in because we're coming
through 306 rules are extremely
important
and the concept I'm I've always thought
of and believe in Thoroughly is that
state statute drives rules rules don't
drive state statute
and that's what we got to make sure that
the rules are reflective of the intent
and the the law that we have put in
place
so that that is all the scheduling which
we have to date there's a lot of other
stuff going on committees and
commissions however that's not our task
here today so what I'd like to do is get
into the three bills which we have down
for today at this time 151 Senate Bill
151 HB 505
and HB 352.
151 is relative to mental health
education
505's relative comprehensive mental
health education in schools and 352
relative to excuse absences due to a
student's mental or Behavioral Health
first one we'll take it as in the order
that we had it on the
Chief present to us so it'd be 352 first
this is relative to excused absences due
to a student's mental or Behavioral
Health
and I think that what we ought to do
because we're
probably going to overlap in our
discussion there's a lot of you know
implications that one bill affects
another one so that's that's good
discussion so let's if you you're if
you're driving home for example you say
well I want to have a definition of
mental health that could be relevant to
any one of these bills and so so
um don't be fearful of not presenting
that question or that discussion just
because we happen to be something on
dealing with absences from school
okay 352. any discussion on it
yes represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair
um on the surface there doesn't appear
to be anything wrong with the idea of
taking a mental health day if that's
necessary uh and we've heard testimony
previously on this that nothing in
current law would prevent a student from
taking a mental health day with the
approval of parents if that's necessary
my concern is that by explicitly putting
this in law when it's already allowed it
does nothing but perhaps incentivize
people toward taking more time away from
school it just doesn't seem necessary
thank you
yes represent cascaden
I agree with representative Belcher
um
when a parent calls that their child is
absent
nobody questions why and nobody needs to
I mean a parent will write a note my
child was sick today or if the parent
has been working with the school
consistently because the child does have
a diagnosis then they're aware of it and
I fear
um that it opens the door
for every teenager who doesn't want to
get up in the morning for whatever
reason
so
I agree
wow
[Laughter]
is there any further discussion on this
represent patent no
I guess my one concern was that what
happens after the parent has called in
and notified that the child is taking a
mental health day if the child if they
called in and said the kid is the
student had a sore throat there might
not be follow-up the student appears in
school the next day but I think this
might be a flag that the child would be
um
that the school would be thinking that
the child needed further intervention
that may or may not be necessary
okay I do have a question for the
committee I'd like to look at number
three
on on the bill which is new language
students shall not have their grades
adversely affected by a lack of class
attendance or participation due to
mental or behavioral health related
excused absences
there are a number of schools especially
high schools saying that in fact my my
grandkids are attending one right now
not in the state but you have to be
there X number of days to complete that
course successfully whether you're out
for mental health or you're out for
medical reason if you're offering
medical reason some kind you can get a
50 a 504
uh plan and supposedly get some support
at home or get it online but are we
giving a really open thing here which is
going to recruit or create a issue for
an instructor in a classroom to ensure
that this student meets the competencies
or the academic standards expected from
this class
question
represent dry
that was a good thank you um that was a
good question I also wanted to just ask
if one through four apply to people with
a health
absence
yes represent Myler yeah I'd like to uh
have a resident superintendent of the
schools
respond to your question
um as you as you look at the issue I
mean it's one thing to have an
incidental you know absence and I think
it's quite another representative
writing mentioned you know you got
somebody who has a a medical issue that
the school is aware of how how at least
in the Berlin school system how did you
handle this kind of uh these four these
four issues represent Cascadia are you
willing to take that question yes
uh thank you
um okay let me quickly scan these but
every school has a policy already in
place about what constitute excuse
absence unexcused absence
if there is someone that has a mental
health condition under the you know is
diagnosed by the dsm-4 manual but they
might also have toxic stress they might
also have PTSD
all of those issues
hopefully the parent has worked with the
school to engage Staffing
and support around that student
so then potentially there could be a 504
plan which is making accommodations
under certain circumstances
and that could be the case with a
particular
situation that has mental or Behavioral
Health that's diagnosed and then the
school supports that with the parent
um
let me look to see what else so it
doesn't matter really if it's physical
illness or mental health or
Behavioral Health
accommodations can be made
under the circumstances
but it's a team effort no one person can
make those decisions when there's a
student that's in trauma can you give me
a a a definition for what is mental
health versus behavioral because this
says mental or Behavioral Health
is there a distinct difference there
between those two topics and if so
how are those diagnosed are they
diagnosed by a professional that the
parent is working with or is the parent
diagnosing this
no they are two different
types of disorders
um somebody with a mental health
disorder would be diagnosed by a
psychologist or a psychiatrist it's very
specific
and they use the DSM-5 manual which is
the list of mental health disorders I
can't remember the formal title there
are people here that know that title
so if there is someone with a eating
disorder if they're being treated they
could have a mental health issue
behavioral issue is someone who lives in
a toxic
environment the parents are drug users
the kid comes to school there hasn't
been any food he's going to act out or
he's going to be introverted
somebody who's experienced their house
burned to the ground they lost
everything that child my experience
post-traumatic stress disorder
so then they may act out over that and
they might just look like they're
naughty kid but they aren't because you
have to delve deeper into social
emotional learning
to find out what is going on with these
kids so no longer is the thought the
kid's naughty in school
give them a day of detention
if a school is set up appropriately to
be that safe environment
um
in a trauma sensitive School
then all kids who have any type of
behavior Outburst including a bully
uh would get some type of scaffolding of
support
so we don't segregate I don't separate
Mental Health
from a toxic toxic stress
so absences really depend on that team
effort what can that child I mean I've
had kids that haven't been able to come
to morning classes for
a behavioral or a mental health issue
or an environmental issue that really is
creating a struggle
and so Alternatives and accommodations
for them to access School are made
specific for that student are there
other questions for the superintendent
representative leckis best going to you
if you're willing to take the question
from her did you signal out or make a
difference between mental health
illnesses and physical illnesses
and why would one be different than the
other
I didn't hear the beginning of your
questions did you did you make a
difference between mental illnesses and
physical illnesses
um
in high in what you did for the kids
no
no depends what the physical illness is
they might have limitations
um they might have capacity issues
so no it's it's very it might have a
crime disease and what they might have
Lyme disease
there might be debilitating they might
yep I've had kids that have you know
they have mono it can't be another rule
so you got to phase that in you got to
support them at home
representative following up the word
that I think uh represent Ruckus was as
a prior Minister and principal myself
we had a rule in the district that if
you're going to be out five days or more
and usually up after the fifth day you
had have a doctor's certificate or some
kind of uh communication from the
psychiatrist which is also that level uh
professional so that it's not abused and
also to afford the school the
opportunity if that student's going to
be out for any extended time you can go
down the route of a 504. absolutely
so is there is it good to have some
qualifying time limits on this otherwise
can a person call in and say well I'm
going to take a mental health week
and I'm going with my folks down to
Myrtle Beach
you know some doctors would write a note
to excuse that because they need a
mental health week but
um don't worry that kind of stuff is not
very secret
I mean word gets out but it's but in
your past history have you had that
limitation of X number days then the
school has the teacher has to received
the note or the reason why the child is
sick yes they have to have so many
unexcused days versus excuse days
and it sometimes it could take a long
time to add up unexcused days and then
you require a doctor's note yeah yeah
yes rep person Damon
thank you Mr chair
so I have a comment on a couple
questions so the DSM that representing
past cotton referred to just to
clarifying that for folks who might know
not know is the diagnostic and
statistical manual it's in its fifth
edition and it's basically the Bible of
diagnosis of mental health conditions
that's used by all Health Care
Professionals it's very standardized and
respected
um
some a question sometimes since my kids
were in school and they happily weren't
ill much in either way physical or
mental
currently if a parent calls to inform
that their student will not be in school
do they have to State a reason
so follow-up yeah so then the written
note would need to stay a reason
like what I'm asking is can a parent
simply call and say Jane will not be in
school today she's not well without
being any further specific than that or
do they need to be more specific when I
was a principal
um that was fine yeah
uh for the parent calling fact we wanted
that to occur but when it went longer
beyond that five-day period then we had
to you know get more specific and that's
where we were asking for the
recommendation or the statement from the
MD or
the counselor or whomever it might be
one more follow-up yes
so
if there was the five-day absence and
therefore the medical or psychiatric
note needed
if for whatever reason the family and or
student does not want to share
the diagnosis for the concern
can that note simply say
you know Dr Smith
affirms that
this student was not well enough to
attend school for these days
as a principal I was never going to
question
the professional statement written by MD
that's not my bailiwick you know you
know
so I wouldn't question if I had a note
from The Physician stating you know they
scribble something down they've had a
paper you can't read it anyways and and
uh that's that's for me that was good
enough we knew that there had been a
diagnosis by a professional not just
either mom or dad or a brother or sister
I don't know if that's where you are a
representative cascadden
um yes
um you don't question it and with a
doctor's note the only thing is you
always had a small pool of kids who were
habitually absent
in either the family or the the child
had a connection in the school so they
didn't have to explain to everybody
maybe it's just a school nurse maybe
it's just a school psychologist
but people within the the institution
would take that word for it without
needing to know any details because some
parents don't want that
um
there are very few times that there are
truancy cases
that are not masking Behavioral Health
or some poor environmental situation
um I've been to more houses to get kids
in the morning from when I was a
principal and a superintendent and
um it's truly an eye-opener
I visited too and I've been welcomed
with a person with a rifle in their hand
um but you know in in the case for
example we had years and years ago we
had a bill in here on concussion injury
and we had folks from the NFL testifying
as well as a young lady who had been in
in college in Massachusetts had a
concussion
and had be home in a dark area until
this was healed that in that particular
case you get the letter from the or the
statement from The Physician but that's
when you also take action at school
saying how can we help how can we
establish now the 504 plan yeah and and
and get going on this so that's why I
think it's necessary to get something
from the doctor in case if it's going to
be an extended period of time then it
takes some time to get the person to go
to you know to hire somebody to take
care of that 504 yep yes representative
Balboni
um this goes to exactly what you were
talking about I just pulled up SEO 50s
policy
um and it and it states essentially what
you are saying I think all districts are
required to have a policy and it
includes the definition of excused
absences details uh
um it talks about the after five days
they'll look into it and it gives so
it's very detailed laid out in in in
what the expectations are for the school
district
further discussion represent a hall
thank you is there a from school to
school district I realize everyone has
to have a policy but from school
district to school district does it vary
a whole lot
like what if a school district said five
days and you particularly high school
because it
you know you got graduation that they're
thinking about where the other schools
not so much
the graduation degree is issued by that
High School
diploma
and of course they said all the
boundaries parameters for issuing that
diploma so I I I don't want to be
subjective and answer that I can't
because I don't know exactly what's
going on throughout the state in this
regard represent Tanner no excuse me
represent cordelli first he had to stand
up and then representative
thank you
um it seems to me with this legislation
it would require
a third category you have excused
unexcused or mental Behavioral Health
reasons for absences
um because with this you it would seem
that you have to track the number of
mental health behavioral health days
that they're absent because you want to
make sure that it's not affecting their
grading or anything else and it also
opens the door as representative
pedernal said
for the school to start raising
questions and it couldn't it doesn't
have to be five consecutive days it
could be you know a couple of days here
a couple of days next month that
um the reason is a quote mental health
or Behavioral Health so I I think this
for me this opens doors that I'm not
sure I would want to go down
forever Santana
so like representative Balboni I looked
up my District's um absentee policy and
it's it's the same thing five five days
and then there's some notification but
it also uh has various categories for uh
excused and unexcused absences and one
of the excuses uh personal illness and
in quotation marks it has mental or
physical so
um I think most of the schools are aware
of that I know we had students that had
um
you know in the in the Dark Ages when I
was teaching
um had uh mental illnesses that you you
would probably uh describe them as that
or even eating disorders that we knew
that they they uh were working with the
school and they missed a number of days
and a lot of times the if the material
couldn't be sent home and effectively
done for teaching they actually hired a
tutor to go to the house uh under a 504
plan so
further discussion representative miler
and clearly the issue of
student mental health is a
been brought to our attention and it's
been all over the news so we know that
this is an issue
and we've also heard
that school districts have in fact
policies that cover this
and I was looking at a couple of the
letters that we received supporting this
particular Bill and what I'm trying to
figure out what is the intent
behind the bill
I mean whenever I look at a bill like
this I I always want to know
why is this being proposed
when there are it appears that there are
already safeguards within school
districts Etc with policies Etc
I mean clearly we want to be able to
protect
the mental health of students Etc but
when I look at a bill like this with all
the safeguards we've just heard about
I just I'm looking at what what is the
maybe maybe we can get an answer from
that if you look at the prime sponsor
and the co-sponsors of this legislation
the prime sponsors in the room
so represent Alexander are you are you
willing to come forward and try to
respond to what was your intent or
rational behind submitting this
thank you for being here
thank you um House Education Mr chair
for the record my name is representative
Alexander I represent the town of
Goffstown
um so I'm the intent of this bill is to
provide a flag and create communication
between parents in the school district
and the students so when we talk about
mental health or mental illness it might
just be one day I'm not feeling well
like I woke up and I just was not
feeling well and
um it could be not anything diagnosed by
a doctor or anything but you know a
student that might need that a little
extra support and if the if this is
flagged for the school district and the
school district knows and the parent
calls in and says my child's taking a
day off maybe the school district can
keep and keep a closer eye on that child
make sure that they're getting the
support that they need I've heard from
multiple parents that sometimes students
fall through the cracks and we just want
to make sure that we're creating a
system where there's more communication
between the parent and School District
especially if their child needs extra
help
so let me follow up and then represent
parano the an item number four here
uh the students shall be considered
present by their school during the
excused absence
if you're declaring that that there are
present but they may have an uh excused
absence because it's it's a mental
health issue
is the school now because the present
responsible for providing that one day
or two day that student's out the
activities which are the academic class
work that's being presented is that we
oftentimes when a kid was absent would
the teacher would follow that up maybe
that evening saying hey you know here's
some things which we're doing you could
be reading this you could be doing a
spelling lesson if it's a grade school
kid Etc are they required Now by saying
you are present so we're going to hold
you accountable for what was taught
during that day well I I think it's
pretty vital that the school gives the
opportunity for the student to miss like
make up that work but this language and
Martha Dickey's here too and she came up
like it was from other states that this
language came from
um it like various different states so
I'm leaving honestly the language up to
the committee I'm happy to come back
with um
language that addresses doctors know
non-doctors know but I just want to make
sure that the intent of the bill is to
protect the student and create more
communication on mental or behavioral
health problems I think representative
I'm just
confused about that because if there's
open communication between the parents
and the school shouldn't the parents
already feel comfortable contacting the
school and say my child might have some
mental health issues and I need some
help dealing with that do you think you
could
offer some suggestions
again as representative Miler said I'm a
little confused as to what the actual
intent is and why this bill is truly
necessary because it does seem like we
have a lot of safeguards for the
students already in place the idea is
thank you the question the idea is that
the parent would call and say can you
please keep a closer eye on my child but
I think that by taking that mental
health day
there
it's it's kind of like an unsaid thing
that maybe they might need that extra
support so
um you know a student might go to their
parent and say I'd like to take the day
off and the parent might not ask any
more questions and they just say I need
to take a mental health day
um
and then it's just something for the
school to follow up with later at some
point
I don't I think
I don't want I know the committee's job
is to overthink but I don't want the
committee to overthink so
um
I don't the language itself in here does
not bother me how it's changed I just
like at least some the state being like
we're going to allow mental health to
give support to those students allow for
more communication with Administration
and teachers and guidance counselors to
make sure that we're protecting all of
them
represent Cornell I I guess if we're
going to put something like that in I
would almost like to put part of the
burden on the parent to say the parent
will contact the school guidance
counselor or the principal rather than
when they call in it's the secretary
who's not only giving everybody admit
slips but answering the phone and that
that will get lost you know quite
honestly if there's one secretary doing
all of that and then to expect the
secretary to pass along the word to a a
guidance counselor in a school say of
Central High School with 2000 students
to pass it along to the guidance
counselor oh so-and-so's mother called
him in today and said that they were
having a rough day that's leaving a lot
to chance I think you know so almost to
say you know if it's some if it's a
personal thing like that get in touch
with someone in the school who can
respond better but also I want to bring
up Manchester for an excusing the
principal or his designee shall
determine if the absence is excuse for
good cause for any other reason not
listed above
which means in that case the parent may
already have been in contact with
somebody and they know what's going on I
just I just don't want it left to change
if if that's going to be the issue you
know let's not leave it to chance of
whoever's answering the phone or if
there's an answering machine in some
schools for for calling out
represent cascadden uh just to add if
you're from Goffstown Goffstown High
School is a PBIS school I don't know if
you're familiar with that it's positive
supports and behavioral interventions
and it functions on a three-tier
framework process so that kids who need
support whether it's mental health or
Behavioral Health
it would be part of that structure
but now that's not saying they're going
to know every single student but it is
designed so that there's a coach that
does get to know every single student so
they do have that model I don't know how
well it's working but um part of the
intent of that whole school structure is
to help and support those kids
represent Tanner
thank you and and kind of in terms of
overthinking something are you needing
to talk to oh the represent any further
um now we can have them sit down oh okay
is there something for him not not
necessarily thank you are there any
other other questions directly for this
man right here not seeing thank you very
much thank you representative Alexander
okay go ahead no so
um this particular bill was set in 189
colon 34 which my book
um I noticed uh kind of open to that
that that it has a section in it a
definition of excused absence and a
process for considering exceptions to
absences not otherwise excuse is one of
the
um parts for the school board policies
and the second part of it is a process
for intervention designed to address
individual cases of truancy as quickly
as possible and I think
we're getting into the to the details
that maybe belong at the local District
level and certainly from the different
schools that we've looked up already
they are following this policy
um
to have definitions of excuse policies
to have a process of intervention as
prescribed in the statutes and I don't
think we need to go into
the detail that's that's in this
particular
um bill I mean I think it's it's
something in New Hampshire we already
have in statute
and follow-up to that representative
Tanner I know that many of the schools
uh if you don't call in you get a call
from them
and I've gotten that many a time in fact
I could have taken a mental health day
today the Carolina Panthers got beat and
and
um I was watching that game I was a
little bit disgusted because I was
hoping that their quarterback would do
something so is that a good is that a
mental health day I don't know but
you don't want to respond to that
represent cordiello
yeah I just have a comment uh
representative Alexander had mentioned
this I think a flag the word flag
sending out the flag
and
as we all know mental illness does have
a stigma and there I'm concerned that
there will be parents who do not want
this flag sent up and so the children in
most need might be those parents in
denial who don't want to have this be
open to or for any reason maybe they
just want to maintain their privacy but
that they don't want that flag sent up
and that a lot of children uh who are
most need of help will will not benefit
I'm just having a really hard time
seeing why we need this so I just wanted
to put my
opinion in there
further discussion from the committee
here
now
okay I don't see any more hands up on
this is there a need for us to one eat
to have the legislation as it is is
there a need to modify it maybe
then we get into some of the policy
decision making of the local school
district like we should be a due to a
diagnosed mental health behavior health
or or that that's that's in the
diagnosis something you want after the
five-day period you the first you don't
you wouldn't have that
um it's just like a medical sort a sore
throat or the flu
um you're out and that's excused so uh I
guess I'm asking is there a need for
um
defining anything in here more so or
clearing up any language or or is there
even a need for the bill
so representative cascad and then
representative dry
are we able to itl this bill yeah oh
yeah well yes you we would recommend it
on that could go to the floor
okay but we will be doing that all that
on in November right yeah yeah
represent dry
thank you I I'm thinking that 2A that's
in here right now with a definition of
excuse absence and a process for
considering exceptions and it's not even
limited to that I mean that's a very
broad statement to to a 2 and 2A I think
it covers everything that we were
talking about and I agree with
representative Tanner that this is
probably best left at the policy level
any further discussion because if you if
we're saying that as as a majority of
people this is left better for
for you know leaving it the way it is in
law
uh we don't have to have any more you
know committee the whole on this bill we
would basically understand where we're
going with
um
at in November
if not we continue to list it
when we meet
representative Damon
so I think I have a different point of
view on this bill than much of what has
been expressed and I'm not entirely sure
how to effectively articulate it
um
I particularly think number one lines
four through six in the draft language
is important
it's just not clear to me given what has
been acknowledged about stigma around
mental health and behavioral health
issues
and I think our broad acceptance that
students today have a high incidence of
those some of those conditions
it's not clear to me that our students
and families always know
that it is an acceptable thing to stay
home for these reasons and
repair yourself basically I was looking
at the testimony that new Futures
submitted when we originally heard this
bill
and if I could there's in their last
paragraph supporting it
um it reads as follows
allowing for mental health absences
removes some of the stigma associated
with having a mental health Challenge
and I think that is part of the intent
of this bill
additionally it ensures that students
are not penalized for having a mental
health challenge just as they wouldn't
be penalized for being physically ill
excusing absences for mental health
ensures that young people can take the
time needed to tend to their well-being
which can help minimize additional
symptoms and give students time to seek
the help they need
so I just kind of wanted to make that
statement that I think there's some
Merit to at least part of this bill
um thank you when the student returns to
school they're going to have to have
some kind of a note or from the parent
or else it's going to go down as an
unexcused absence
the only way you're going to have it is
an excused absence is if there's a note
from the parent or Guardian is that
correct
if I'm asking anybody on the committee
here three days you have to have a note
if you're if you're out for more than
three days according to the policy here
there has to be a written note submitted
by the parent
um so what happens in those schools
which
say if you have so many unexcused days
you can either drop to grade level or or
something occurs I know that for a fact
in a school where my your grandkids are
going around silver a thousand kids in
the school
um according to this after five days of
unexcused absences the principal will
begin an intervention with the student
the students parents Guardians and other
staff members as may be deemed necessary
and then it goes through a list of what
the intervention should involve so if
it's less than five how do we know the
kid's Point not playing hooky
is there no note that comes in for that
day of absence how does the parent know
the kid did not go to school that
happened with number one right here
where I didn't go to school and I showed
up with the RCMP bringing me to school
and and so that didn't go over well with
my dad
that's why most schools did call back
yeah that's why there has to be some
kind of communication even on one day
the absence right
it's also a safety issue
where's the kid
right I mean maybe something happened if
he was a walker I mean you got to get
your car and go look yeah right
um
I think we don't give schools enough
credit
we're dealing with this I mean this is
mental health is not new schools have
had to deal with it as far back as 10
years 15 years where they had to start
putting in structures within the system
to be able to open
to not shunning kids who are having
mental health or behavioral health
issues
um
okay so I think what we'll do because we
have two other bills and I want to get
them this morning as well
um
there there has been some difference in
opinion here on this uh I want everybody
just to think about this as we're going
through the other two bills and reflect
back is this something we need or we
don't need or we need with some a
changing language in it and we can put
it on the docket for the next time we
meet and try to you know put it to bed
at that time
is that okay with everybody
it's a Rick can I add something yeah
thanks thank you very much Mr chair
um I I know I was I was out for a few
minutes but um uh but I believe
representative Tanner talked about a
little bit about the section that this
is in 189.34 which is truant officers
and um and
you know I think maybe a lot of people
think that maybe you know truancy or
true in officers is something from a
bygone day
um I don't recall during my 12 years on
a school board that we ever approved or
appointed truant officers in the uh in
the Hopkins school districts but I think
something that that has been discussed
as a concern of this committee and um
and I don't think we've done much on
this is the um is the the
precipitous drop in
um admr adma whichever one you want to
you want to call it Statewide from about
165 000 K-12 students to now about 159
158 000 and and it didn't happen as a
result of the
one-ish percent uh decline that we've
seen over over the last couple decades
it it came very abruptly uh during and
following covid and and it hasn't really
rebounded and so so
um there seems to be somewhere around
four or five thousand students that that
may be
impacted on this that our school
districts
um probably would have had enrolled but
we haven't seen
we don't know where these kids are
they're not in Nest they're not in
public schools they're not in private
schools they're not in homeschool census
they're you know they're they're they're
they're they're not part of the EFA
program none of the other numbers have
have sort of gone up with
um
um to to make up for this out of trend
uh drop in um in enrollment so I just
sort of put it out there Mr chair that
that this section I think
sure she does the yeah so I'll put it
out there
this section could be used by this
committee to uh to be amended and and
maybe maybe request the Department of
Education to uh to you know report out
on what's happened with these um with
these five six
thousand students that that are no
longer in um uh enrolled in um in our
public schools and don't appear to be
enrolled in any other educational
setting including efas including
Charters including
um
um uh home school
settings uh and I know it's different
than the than the than the purpose of
the bill but uh but it might be a useful
purpose
um
in this in this section but I just sort
of put it out there uh because I I don't
want to lose I don't want to I don't
want this committee to lose the fact
that um that that we've seen a
precipitous covid related decline that
has not bounced back where are these
students because we do have a
constitutional obligation to provide a
adequate opportunity for an adequate
education for them
okay so what we will do is we'll bounce
into the other two here but I would
suggest that if you have
uh
a desire to possibly amend this or
delete part of this whatever you may or
there might be some saying I don't want
it that's fine but there if you want to
try to put some bullets down that we can
share when you come next time if an
amendment has to be made we can address
those write down the numbers here and
and then uh come out with something
possibly towards the latter part of the
meeting a lot of good discussion here on
that and it's related to the next Bills
which are coming up here so with that
let's get into 505
uh relative to comprehensive mental
health education in schools
what I want to do for everybody here
um I'm going to pass out to you the
curriculum we have for health education
framework
it's a copy which has been approved by
the State Board of Education I'll be
albeit back in 2003
but it's the most recent
I'm also going to hand out to everybody
a copy of the
40 rules here
which I did last time
handed out
um
also
I got a report here back from
the Department of Education on a report
in health and physical education
curriculum in the schools what's being
taught or what's not being taught it's a
survey of all the school districts in
the state
I'm also passing out to you uh the
t-e-e-t-e-a school uh Texas Education
Agency doe Texas uh they have a mental
health uh program as well and they
Define what a comprehensive School
mental health program is in this
legislation they have
and just hopefully I'm splitting these
things up right so everybody can have a
copy
and lastly for your feedback here or
here's uh
I took this off the web the other night
uh dealing with resiliency and mental
health resources available in for
schools in Florida
if anybody doesn't get a copy let me
know and we'll see if we can balance it
out
should be enough
yeah okay great thank you
and lastly there's a form here which is
put together by Jennifer four
responding to that survey that was put
out to schools
and it's kind of like a synopsis of
who said yes who said no
are there any extras down on that one
over there
yeah
that's the one from Florida
okay
okay once again HP 505 relative
comprehensive mental health education in
schools
okay we have a lot of paperwork in front
uh just for a you can all scan through
the health education curriculum
guidelines which we have in the state
which also State and address mental
health education
8306 has a specific area where mental
health is identified as an element
within the health program that's
8306.40.
and then the other sheets which came out
this one right here is the survey sheet
which was done of all the school
districts's annual thing which is done
in terms of are you addressing these
issues which we have in statute being
physiology hygiene health education as
it relates to effects of alcohol and
drugs physical
well there you go
that's about doe certification
or maybe even something else who knows
going on across there fiscal education
as it relates to effects of alcohol and
drugs child abuse
human
immunodeficiency virus HIV Acquired and
AIDS and sexually transmitted disease
whether those things are being taught in
schools or not it's kind of interesting
what uh she found out there's a
some schools are not doing that
uh and then of course the sheets are
from Texas and Florida I think that's
all that I handed out to you so it's
open to discussion right now on on this
the on this bill 505 dealing with a
comprehensive mental health uh
representative Belcher
thank you Mr chair and I also took the
liberty of providing some handouts that
I'd like to go through real quick to I
think get a better grasp of what we're
looking at and what we may be looking at
here don't worry we're not going to go
through all of it you're welcome to read
it all head to toe on your own we're
just going to hit some highlights
so we didn't get a lot of
um real firm information as to the full
scope of what constitutes comprehensive
or even just regular mental health
education so I figured one of the best
places to look at where we might be
headed would be to go to the school
Counselors Association
this is the the Professional
Organization that sets the standards and
ethics guidelines for school counselors
who provide Mental Health Services in
schools
first handout labeled with the one on
top identifies one such core directive
of their Association
to be Embrace their role as social
justice Advocates and change agents
in developing this particular position
statement they cite a number of
resources which are on the back page
including ibrahimax candies how to be an
anti-racist
moving on to the second handout we have
an article from eSchool news a popular
online website for school
news and information written by the
director of Behavioral Health for hazel
Health regarding expanding mental health
and Health Services in schools wherein
they specifically talk about providing
students access to confidential Health
Care
they cite mental health symptoms they
particularly would like to bring in
confidential Telehealth services for
students they cite that they may not be
receiving enough or any support from
parents or Guardians in other words they
must go around them to provide these
health services at school
moving on to the Third
handout also from the American School
Counselors Association I believe this
one's even more important than the first
one because this identifies the
standards that they have developed the
competencies
for students under their care
there's a lot of stuff you can look
through here I've highlighted a number
of things not not everything highlighted
is necessarily bad or anything a lot of
it's just interesting stuff worth
looking more into but I would like to
direct your attention to the lower right
hand corner of the second page should be
on the back
bss10 cultural awareness sensitivity and
responsiveness now if you go through the
rest of this document there will be a
lot of other
references to that specific item so what
is
cultural learning sensitivity and
responsiveness bringing us to the fourth
handout from the publication Ed week one
of the most preeminent education
Publications
what is culturally responsive teaching
again you're free to go through this top
to bottom on your own we're just going
to look at a couple highlights
on the let's see here
second page so on the back it identifies
that a number of states have passed
legislation seeking to prohibit the
teaching of critical race theory in
schools and it notes that that does in
fact affect this cultural culturally
responsive teaching
going on to the next page
it identifies the start of culturally
responsive teaching as being the work of
Gloria Ladson Billings the author of the
book toward a critical race theory of
Education
it further identifies that this concept
seeks to accept and affirm the cultural
identity while developing critical
perspectives
all in all what this appears to be is
teaching students to identify by race
and class and other characteristics
moving on again to the next page at the
top it's specifically identifies
critical Consciousness as one of the
core competencies of this critically or
culturally relevant teaching critical
Consciousness derives from critical
theory which was the work of neo-marxist
horkheimer in his book uh traditional
versus critical theories written in the
1930s
moving on Lower in the page
we see that this particular
competency they're pushing it divides
people on Race racial and ethnic groups
and it assumes that people have
different cultures and traditions within
America based on the color of their skin
and that they need to teach to that
moving on even further to the next page
we see that culturally responsive
teachers must also consider the students
gender age socioeconomic status where
they live Etc
this is intersectional Theory cranberry
Crenshaw in her relatively famous paper
mapping the margins
finally on the last page
at the very bottom
we identify for instance students and
high school math class could learn about
statistics by assessing the
probabilities of racial profiling cases
in various neighborhoods or using other
data sets applicable to their
communities that bring up questions
about Justice and Injustice
this is talking about hijacking the
curriculum for social justice ends this
is directly out of the Playbook of a
gentleman named Paolo frieri his book
pedagogy the oppressed which is
unbelievably become one of the most
popular books
handout 5 is just further
clarification on exactly where this
Theory and ideas come from
and further evidence on page six out of
the University of California Fresno we
have heard about why is compassionate
framework before this is a term that's
come up a number of different times
why is compassionate framework in
teaching health education in schools
embodies critical race Theory
multi-tiered systems of support old
school whole Community model
trauma-informed practices social justice
responsibility and evidence-based
research
so I think this really gives us a little
bit of an idea of where the door to
mental health education of students is
open to
particularly from the closest current
professional association being the
student Counselors Association
thank you you have a question
representative cordelli thank you
um you know I will take a closer look at
the school counselor information but
perhaps you can explain how the rest of
these documents like the culturally
responsive teaching is related to the
legislation that we are discussing well
I think before we get into another you
know 25 minutes and trying to find all
that I think we need to stick to the
topic and which is there's three words
that have been are for that have been
put into this legislation comprehensive
mental health education that's that's it
underneath studies
so
um I'd rather not get into that right
now and I'd like to try to get
when we initially had this bill here
there was a concern do we call this
comprehensive mental health education or
mental health education uh then we saw
mental health written in ed306 it's also
within the Frameworks which were
required to be teaching right now the
reason why you see the uh what they've
done in Texas uh before you at the
bottom of that first page it gives a
definition as to what comprehensive
mental health is this is coming out of a
pretty conservative state
and you can see that they it says
comprehensive School Mental Health
Systems provide a Continuum of services
and supports intended to and you see the
bullets in the back page promote a
positive School climate teach and
support skills for social emotional
Behavioral Health prevent mental health
and substance use problems intervene
early to reduce the severity of mental
health concerns and the last one provide
access to school-based and
community-based interventions and sports
to students and families and you get
down a little lower they talk about the
mtss which is the multi-tiered system of
support which I think we have something
very similar that operating in our state
right now so that's their definition and
I'd like to stay you know somewhere
along the ballpark of what I just read
because that seems to me is what we're
dealing with and in my discussions with
many superintendents now there appears
to be
a need for looking at mental health or
comprehensive mental health and the
conditions the students are coming to
school in right now and some of the
really issues in the classroom the
teachers are having to address and deal
with
so representative Damon
thank you Mr chair and thank you
particularly for framing the discussion
around what this bill proposes to do
which is mental health education
I would very respectfully ask my
colleagues to carefully distinguish
between education and treatment
they are not the same thing that would
be true whether we were talking about
physical health mental health or
whatever
I see this bill as a necessary statement
of requiring that we educate our
students
about conditions of mental health so
that they learn
protective factors risk factors and
where help would be available should
they or folks they know need it
it is not about providing treatment
that's part of mental health system but
it's not education
if I parallel it to a physical condition
if we teach students what diabetes is
what symptoms would suggest that you
might want to get evaluated for diabetes
we're not treating them if they do turn
out to have diabetes they will be
treated in the Health Care system
similarly if we teach students what the
warning signs of depression or anxiety
disorder are we're not treating them
we're informing them that these
conditions exist
and that because they're common
it is part of their education to be
aware of them and informed for future
reference
so I really urge people try diligently
pleased to distinguish between education
and treatment
this bill does not propose that schools
be treating mental health it proposes
that we be educating about it
thank you
representative
thank you very much Mr chair and thanks
for for getting us back on track on here
and I think uh representative Damon said
it very well what um some of your
remarks Rick and and hope reminded me of
a um a speaker that that many of us I
think may have heard last summer at CSG
East which was hosted in Manchester and
they had a speaker who's the president
of Bank of America
based out of Connecticut and uh and he
was
he was really up there to speak about
internships and and Workforce
Development and uh and he said but I'll
tell you I'll tell you this is this is
you know a room full of legislators from
across the country including a lot from
New Hampshire and goes I'll tell you the
biggest the biggest thing where where
concerned that we're seeing among
um uh interns that we take you know out
of out of high school is
um is is mental health and and he said
it and it has it has dropped on us like
a ton of bricks right now and it's not
something that had really um been on
their radar screen several years ago but
absolutely was as a as an employer as a
um uh someone that run that that
supervises interns in their in their
business and
um and again the president Bank of New
Hampshire and he said please please do
something about uh bringing this to uh
to light in your in your public schools
and talking about it and eliminating the
stigma about it so that um
so that people could um could could
get the help that they need
well that's old-fashioned it right
represent Danner
thank you
um I'm just asking a question about
um
the bill as it's written and
um looking at uh the page that you
handed out with 189 colon 10 studies
um this there's a lot more in 189 10
then uh is in this first and second
paragraph
um are we proposing to
change
this particular 189 10 sections one and
two
um and actually they have a section
three
by eliminating those and just uh
inserting this is that is that the
intention of this law of this particular
I think the way this is written
representative Tanner is that it's just
adding to that Roman 2 the four words
comprehensive mental health education
and not doing anything to any any other
statute of legislation that's in place
there's no other changes there's no
deletion
according to exercise of other Roman
numerals which might appear I I don't
have that law in front of me I'm looking
at just the background there's a section
three with a personal financial literacy
yeah that remains that remains there
that doesn't go anywhere and then it has
three the C 306 rules which
um you know are the the course in high
school that I taught in health was a
quarter credit it was you know one
marking period uh for you know 45
minutes a day five days and to actually
achieve all these things
um would be very difficult although
they're all integrated you know
everything's kind of integrated in
itself like physiology can't be
separated from what you're teaching when
you're teaching Health but
um or PE but um
even in the 306 rules it actually uh
under part two G it has mental health
um so you know it isn't that we aren't
doing it already it's I you know I just
think these bills are pointing out that
we have a mental health crisis and with
kids and I we're all aware of that and I
think schools are are extremely aware of
it now
um as are the communities and and I
appreciate the fact that people are
putting in
bills to try to highlight it but it's
already there
um so
yes it definitely is already identified
in a number of places
um
go ahead
no you represent paranol you haven't
spoken yet on this this one
and then representative cascadden thank
you um
am I correct this health education
curriculum guidelines is from 2003 yes
so it's 20 years old
yeah and our social studies was written
in 2006 so it's just about as old well
our second page it says page five number
one is health education
and if you go down to the the second
line well I'll read it a planned
sequential K-12 program that addresses
the physical mental emotional and social
dimensions of Health
and then go down further reduce health
related risk behaviors I would say we've
been covering this at least for 20 years
so I'm kind of questioning the necessity
of this
particular bill yeah and then if you
look internally you would find a whole
section on Mental Health within it
um
representative and then representative
cardelli thank you
um
the language in this bill the words
comprehensive in education make me
nervous because it gives the perception
now that there'll be
specific learning
of mental health or for mental health
students
um
I I don't understand
why we just don't have mental health
like we do I think we have it in the law
or we have it we have it identified
already in the 306s
but this work schools have recognized
that this is an issue quite a while ago
because there have been initiatives
through this office of Wellness which
came about because of some of this
um 10 years ago again schools went to
positive behavioral intervention
supports it was Project aware that was
building resilience among kids
um
the thing is the school
should not be perceived as the place
that's going to cure someone with a
mental health disorder
it needs to be one piece of the puzzle
because a child will spend five or six
hours there
so behavior is important
there has to be a connection in a
relationship with Community Health
physical health
mental health professionals in the
community or in the region but there has
to be a Continuum of services and it's
not just the school and I fear that
because this now comes as a new
a new bill
the schools now need to take on curing
mental health issues
and it really should not be
separated out again as a mental health
issue because kids come to school with
other emotional and Behavioral
issues and some students have their
mental health very well under control
you know so
I don't like separating that out I think
that puts labels on kids
the other pieces
um I lost my train I thought schools
have gone
from detentions
to student support centers
in their schools which is part of the
structure that if a student needs a time
out
he might go to a student Support Center
I'd be curious to know
maybe the office of Wellness you know at
the doe can find out how many schools
already have a multi-tiered systems of
support for emotional behavioral and
mental health conditions
but I think if there's any language
comprehensive in education should come
out because
it's already being done
and to what extent should the school be
dealing with mental health
I mean it's not in their purview to
sort of change that
it's their responsibility to make sure
that the student is safe
in a learning environment
and so it's a different
to me it's a different picture
but
um
I think the curriculum and the education
about it is is already there in the
health curriculum
but one piece that I can remember adding
was training staff and being able to
recognize
mental health disorders
and that was through the training of all
staff and youth Mental Health First Aid
Just Like You Train everybody annual in
bullying
um You Train everybody annually and some
other requirements but I think that
would be a key factor to add
to at least train all staff people in
recognizing that to so that they can
refer
um you know students and help the
student but not cure it it's not their
job
representative I completely agree with
representative Cass cat and on that on
the staff
being trained better
um I have a family member with a mental
illness if I thought for a minute that
this sort of thing would have helped her
with her situation I'd be all for it but
I don't think it would have and we're
already feeling apparently we're already
addressing these issues I don't like
this phrase comprehensive mental health
education
either I want to thank representative
Belcher for these handouts which are
relevant he brings up very complicated
issues regarding regarding Marxist
ideology
um and the fact the American school
counselor Association
seems to
express some
concerning terms that that sends up a
flag for me
um I and I feel like this putting this
phrase in here Comprehensive Health
education opens a door to Association
like this
bringing that ideology into the schools
I've seen it in the libraries with the
American Library Association with their
Marxist ideology
so that's what concerns me
um
that is all
just follow up just a quick one I mean
you had some examples here from Texas
and Florida but I would suggest people
look at Massachusetts and their statute
um
requires all schools to have they call
it a safe and supportive environment and
then there are specific guidelines that
all schools must follow
to be able to help students who have
mental health disorders who have been
traumatized there's a lot of research on
trauma sensitive schools using the aces
to be able to identify and support kids
so just another resource that I think
would be strongly but isn't that in
conjunction with mtss which is the
multi-tiered system where it may not be
part of tier one but you you get into
those other levels where you're dealing
now with the professionals not the
schools we're not asking a teacher to be
a professional and I think that's when I
initially heard that I said well all of
a sudden we're going to make you know
our our our teachers psychiatrists the
MD type level or even a psychologist or
our counselor and that's you know that
that's not their job
um
so I I I I feel that part of this is
also on training of our our teachers to
know how to deal with issues and that's
why I put forth the issue dealing with
the the the information that came out of
uh Florida and on page
uh at the back of that whole Litany of
stuff there
um on pages 10 and 11 there's underlined
there and one of the without not going
through and reading it all it talks
about expanding school-based mental
health care training Educators and other
staff and detecting responding to mental
health issues and connecting children
youth families who may experience
behavioral health issues with
appropriate services
so the school is not going to be
necessarily that service it's you know
like when I was a principal I had
Community Mental Health housed in my
building right
and we work jointly together and it
worked miracles
right there's nothing that prevents a
provider from coming on site represent
cordelli thank you I'd like to go back a
little bit
um we're talking about the Frameworks
and then just point out that mental
health as was mentioned is included in
here but also broken down by elementary
middle and high school sections which I
think is important and I was not here
for the last
um
session of this on these bills but I
watch much of the video and one thing
that struck me someone mentioned
um are we contributing to the problem
um and I think that can't be dismissed
either you know I've got articles here
does high school cause team team
depression can school cause depression
um
can school cause mental illness
talking about colleges and
safe spaces
there's a book coming out dealing with
social media and smartphones and taking
phones away from uh kids but also you
know we've talked about before
the drugs that kids are put on for hdhd
ETC and here's a warning article about
the shortage of those medications and
what what impact is that going to have
on mental health so I I think that
besides you know addressing you know
mental health in the curriculum I think
the system has to take a look inwards as
well
further discussion represent Belcher
thank you Mr chair and I'd like to I'd
like to heavily agree with what rep
cordelli just said and I think we
actually need to rewind this all the way
to the beginning not not just to this
bill but even to this 2003 outline and
we have to ask ourselves also a
fundamental question because the premise
is seemingly assumed that public schools
can and should be doing something to
solve this problem
and I think we need to actually tease
out that argument is that something that
needs to be done at public schools and I
to offer just one anecdote toward that
we heard moving testimony from a young
lady last session right here
who testified not specifically to mental
health she was testifying on Civics but
she testified to her mental health
difficulties
that were breaking her down as a student
she nearly cried in testimony
and the reason that she was doing that
and because she made this very explicit
was that the problems of the world from
climate change to racism were on her
shoulders and she learned this in public
school
so we need to think a real hard look
Inward and see are we put in the
problems of the world on teenagers and
asking them to solve these problems
because that isn't something that should
be their job right now
representative Cascade that's why
parents have choice
representative Damon
I just want to observe that
wow
mental health education is in
the 189 10 and helpful to have that hand
out in front of us thank you
quite frankly I am not confident that in
our present process in education in New
Hampshire through Doe
that if mental health is not included in
the RSA as a topic of Education
that it will stay in the 306 rules and
therefore I vigorously support that it
be included as a law that we provide
mental health education that's one of
the reasons why we have the ed306 rules
the Draft rules
a session for us to look at and discuss
here because that is one of the
components which is stripped from the
proposed rules
306.40 is those elements of Mental
Health Nutrition and all that that come
underneath are gone
that's the same thing in in social
studies and Science and all that the the
elements within those topical subject
areas are gone
well so they're gone from rule then
where is there any reference to that in
statute well we have in Statue already
where a reference is health and
interpersonal relationships Health
meaning well what is health then we go
to 306 and we gave rulemaking authority
to the state board and they defined what
else was they've approved that in their
framework and their academic standards
and so somewhere along the way I I think
we need to have health education
specified in statute if not in mental
health which is a component within
health
uh I have no problem with that either
but we have a lot of areas within health
education and we've addressed some of
the substance abuse that's in under
these studies right now the difference
between this field and the next bill
which we discuss is that one of them's
looking at putting language in the
studies 189 the other is looking at 193
adequate education
where health education already is in law
so I I guess that that's what we got to
really be focused on now is in in the
word comprehensive is comprehensive out
is that all out right there do we need
it that's that's the question I would I
would ask the committee here
any takers
no represent cascad I agree the adequate
education standards includes Health yes
Health includes mental Wellness
and then it makes a reference to the
substance abuse stuff as an RSA
following that under the adequacy 193e
but then if we take it out of 306 see
there's no backup for mental health
I I think that you're correct I think it
should be left in the rules
representative
I've been puzzled by this all along
because
trying to parse this it talks about all
these things that need to be taught to
people's pupils and then it goes on as
they relate to the effects of alcohol in
a sexual violence and whatever
and are we only teaching those as they
relate to those things or should we be
teaching as well those the effects of
alcohol and other drugs because
I don't know maybe it's me but the way
I'm reading it it seems because it says
as they relate to
means the things before that are taught
as they relate to the things after that
and I don't think was that what was
intended I mean
Jen did for us
you're going to see one of the areas
health education as it relates to the
effects of alcohol and drugs right we
have 233 schools responding yes we do it
and we have 14 Schools saying no we
don't so my question is was this put in
to say that these things need to be that
the focus was
alcohol and drugs sexual violence that
you know the the the things that it's
talking as they relate to
and the idea of
um the things being taught physiology
hygiene Etc is is someplace else
and this bill was just saying that we
also have to be in use use those things
to teach
um the effects of alcohol and drugs Etc
so why was this
why was this originally put into law and
what was the point because it seems to
me in reading it the point was dealing
with
alcohol drugs child abuse HIV Etc
and it seems like those other things
show up elsewhere as teaching them and
are only mentioned here is the way as
what we're using to point out these
other things so it's a question I don't
know please explain
representative and then represent
cordial thank you I
as we're looking at this I remember when
we first when we had this first hearing
and this whole section
189 colon 10 Roman numeral two really
needs an entire revision because it's
like a Dumping Ground for the the latest
health issue of the day and I think we
could tighten that up so that it
encompasses a lot more
in broader language in one section
rather than starting to delineate each
and every single malady as it
comes across the legislature
that's a that's a cleanup that if you
knew
uh the folks that were in OLS prior when
Anthony was there this is an echo you
just echoed what Anthony was saying that
we we either put a subject area in under
adequacy or you dump it into studies
and
that that's you know that's uh something
that has to be answered because we've
sort of been dumping in both places
and every time you enter any something
into adequacy you're talking about the
requirement for funding that as well
so we'd dump it into studies and like
personal finance literacy we did that
and you mesh it either into your course
of Economics you're teaching or into the
classroom in the grade schools or are
you teaching us a separate class
so
it's an age-old issue to address
yes represent cordial well I think
grammatically it's just a mess because
now I see what you're saying it doesn't
make any sense I don't know if it's a
misplaced modifier or what but when you
get to the end it does sound like all
the whole list is only in its
relationship the effects of alcohol and
other drugs and I don't think that's
what was intended but the way I could
see where it's very confusing so it
seems like one of the things I want that
you need to address is alcohol and drugs
but that's separate but so anyway yeah
grammatically a mess too
yeah
further discussion on on this bill
yes
thank you
so I don't know if this is a appropriate
uh
request
but I would wonder if we could maybe do
a strop hole of if the word
comprehensive was removed
but the words mental health education
were
inserted so right now all the bill does
was put those four words in
serting inserting which number no
removing the words comprehensive and
leaving mental health education
I'm just wondering if
I could get some feedback on how people
would perceive it
in the absence of the word comprehensive
okay tagging in on that and then
representative Hall uh if you look at
the 306 rules right now
and it'd be the on the
at the section two which I'm looking at
it identifies a plan K through 12
curriculum and health education designed
to teach the skills listed in the above
across the following content areas of
health education
a through I are we supposed to now
remember this is this is rules so we we
tell
the the rules what should rule should be
but if if we were to put everything
that's in rule into statute it'd be a
whole lot more than just you know it
would be alcohol and drug use prevention
injury prevention nutrition physical
activity family life and comprehensive
sexuality education tobacco use
prevention mental health personal
consumer health community and
environmental health
should we list all those under studies
well I'm asking anybody here you know
it's it goes back to what represents
better now was just saying you know do
we dump it there or we just go with the
definition of health education and and
give rulemaking authority to the
department State Board of Education to
define those Elements which are within
what are the academic standards for
those that are and it's also within
minimum schools standards for public
school approval which are these rules
represent dry
thank you following up on that I just
like page 10 in there kind of this is
the national standards right age 10 is
the health education curriculum and
that's this is what I think the national
education standards are thinking when
they think about health and I think that
everything you talked about is in here
but not necessarily has to be in statute
and see those what you're looking at
were the old Frameworks
which gave guidance to how to teach
though towards those academic standards
for all these subject areas that's the
way we did it
and but we don't have Frameworks anymore
within statute they're gone
yes representative excuse me I'm sorry
uh I would like to answer representative
Damon's question actually I think
comprehensive is the intent of the bill
I think if you take out comprehensive go
back to what we have so I I remember the
testimony it was all about this you know
calling it comprehensive this all
encompassing all the new stuff out there
and whatnot just
okay you're welcome
and do we go and write a definition for
comprehensive mental health would we
borrow for example from that Texas
definition which then later on gets into
the even the the three-tier system mtss
yes
so the Texas information you provided is
more than education
its systems
so those five bullet points at the top
of the second page
um not all of that is education
so that's more than what I perceive this
bill proposing to I agree I agree but
that's part of something that schools do
they do provide assistance and direction
I'm not saying they shouldn't do that
I'm just differentiating it from what I
think the intent of this bill is
and it goes on it says comprehensive
School Mental Health Systems Support the
safety academic success and well-being
of students
foreign do we need all that language in
statute or is that part of rulemaking
right
yes representative
I think
if we just leave all this up to
rulemaking and we don't give some
Direction
we we basically left It Wide Open if we
just say mental health you decide what
it is we're not giving any direction and
it could be anything depending upon
who's writing the rules that any
particular time
and I kind of don't see that as
something we should be doing
but if you get specific remember we
don't write curriculum we don't control
instruction that is a local Education
Agency
responsibility but is curriculum
what is exactly curriculum because I've
been reading all of 306.
and it seems like there's an awful lot
of stuff it seems like there's a big
disagreement here between what
curriculum is because 306 tells all
kinds of things goes into all kinds of
details
that we always say oh we shouldn't be
doing because that's curriculum but 306
isn't local either it's the state
telling the towns what to do so where is
that line between what the state should
be telling them and what they should be
deciding because yeah
lots of details the state has given
guidance through the curriculum
Frameworks
which incorporate the academic standards
now we may say some things in the
academic a curriculum Frameworks that
you're going to teach about Thomas
Jefferson every school may not teach
about Thomas Jefferson but they're going
to teach that academic standards through
maybe some different approach of doing
that so I just took an off the wall type
you know so
I I and I I think we made a mistake as a
legislator and I was the one that's
probably pushing this because the
Statewide assessment wasn't measuring a
lot of this stuff we took curriculum
Frameworks out of law
and I've introduced legislation again
putting it back in this go around
and putting curriculum Frameworks back
in as a guidance and you know we're not
telling what their curriculum
instructions going to be but we're
giving guidance this is how we
incorporate academic standards into what
we're doing if we don't have something
such as that
how do how do you know teachers know
what I should what I should be doing or
shouldn't be doing
so I I don't know I'm not really
supportive of the word comprehensive I'm
I'm in support of the word mental health
being in law
uh it's just another laundry list of an
element within Health that we already
have and so if something comes out of
306 we have it where you are going to be
teaching it because it's in
in statute
for the discussion representative it
already says Health it says you know
find five
health health hygiene health and
interpersonal relationships it doesn't
say physical health it just says health
I don't see the need for any addition
okay represent kiskin
um my when I'm looking at at both of
these the
was it the 151
can't remember
um
and the 505 you know I think that it it
doesn't need to be in statute because
it's already addressed I think the best
place to
specifically identify mental health
skills
is in the rule making that describes
what components schools need to have
when I'm looking at the Texas one
promote a positive School climate teach
and support skills for social emotional
behavioral needs and you know most
schools have social emotional learning
going on prevent mental health and
substance use problems how can they
intervene provide access to school-based
and community-based interventions and
supports to students and families and I
would see that in a rule-making
description of mental health or
behavioral health because once you start
listing all of the different components
like bullying cyber bullying panic
attacks depression
I mean something else is going to come
up and it's not going to be in the list
I I think it's risky to list
all of those things
because it could be again a
post-traumatic disorder it could be a
toxic living and toxic stress a lot of
kids live in that environment it could
be the parents that have the mental
health issue and the student doesn't
know how to deal with it I just worry
that by listing all of those pieces
were um
were too boxed in in terms of Aloft but
if you have some regulated
structures within a school of what needs
to exist and again you know 10 15 years
ago that's how positive behavior
intervention Sports came about over time
I've seen behavioral specialists added
to School school Personnel I've seen Ed
assistants trained in ABA which is
um behavioral
management from cognitive behavioral
Theory I've seen student support centers
grow
in place of detention Halls
um
and those all address how kids
adapt and behave in a school so I'd like
to see it rulemaking
that would include staff
professional development
not in a statute I think mental health
covers it enough
because it should a statute to in my
mind should be Broad
and then
the 306s should be a little bit more
descriptive
and then the district identifies what
works for them
so are you nailing this down so you
think that the rather than Comprehensive
Mental Health it should be just mental
health in statute or you're saying it
should be just health and how we
regulate this we don't have regulations
feds do but we how we will make we put
into rule making what health education
is we don't do that though the State
Board does that
I I worry about a statute specifically
identifying mental health does does is
the perception of mental health
something that's diagnosed in a DSM
manual
or does it also include
other disorders ADHD behavioral social
bullying is is a social you know
Behavior
does mental health pocket it too much
versus health because it's all of this
all of these list of things in this
in this draft bill you know talks about
biological social environmental
influences on Mental Health mental
health disorders anxiety depression
sets of compulsive
um
you know there's a whole list of things
I'm looking are you looking at the rules
right now I'm looking at the draft 151
are you looking at 151 yeah that's the
other bill that's the other one we
talked about yeah okay I I think it I I
would be worried that something would be
missing from that
okay representative
I agree with you to representative
cascaden
um I think the danger with 151 is that
this is going to become another Dumping
Ground like
um like the studies you're going to keep
adding
items to the list each year as some new
Melody du jour appears
chair yeah yeah just to add to that what
I find is the stumbling block
is that some parents are not cooperative
with trying to get treatment for their
kids not all parents but occasionally
you get parents that don't you know
really don't want you to know what's
really going on if your parents are drug
dealers
they'll do anything to like you know
they'll go to open house and put on a
nice space
but deep down when that kid comes and
he's pretty sullen
you know that parent doesn't want you to
dig into the
the behaviors of that kid and that's the
challenge
um
that is a challenge but I'd be curious
to know
how many schools are not really engaged
in some of these
um structures as a whole school
and I don't know if officer students
will show you some of that information
it did show some but it didn't really
not all of it I I yeah there are some
topics here that it would be interesting
to see I mean because you don't want to
stigmatize kids because it's not their
fault
yes represent Belcher thank you Mr chair
um it was mentioned earlier that we
should be a bit introspective and look
at what has been done in the past and
why students might be having some mental
health problems on that note I would let
I would look to the the health education
curriculum guidelines from New Hampshire
from 2003
page 117
left hand side items 3.8 3.9 and 3.10
this is Middle School curriculum
how to advocate for needs and rights of
others how to advocate for a healthy
social environment how to advocate for
fairness and over on the other side it
says students must show awareness of
audience and demonstrate passion and
conviction in other words we have had
guidelines for middle schools for 20
years in this state to train students as
social activists in schools maybe we
should look at that
I'm sorry I I can't let that go
try to provide awareness for students is
not training it's not training them to
be activists
and I I object to the accusation that's
what's happening at school so just to
follow up or where you are
representative Miler uh give you an
example occurred three days ago or four
days ago last Friday
our kindergarten grandson was again put
in the thinking chair
and the thinking chair in the
kindergarten class is where you think
about which what choice you just made
it's a way of addressing an issue and
that was the second time he'd been in
the thinking chair in the last three
days and he came back and explained it
to us and he's the youngest one in the
class but he's also the largest one in
the kindergarten class the birthday just
this last month so that was something
the teacher has responsibility for
teaching you don't start laughing out
loud at somebody else you think about
and you make that choice but his
response was while so and so made me do
that now he has to learn that that comes
from inside you do it yourself
so I think that's part of what a teacher
teaches in kindergarten everything you
know in life you learn in kindergarten
and and so I think that teachers all the
way through these grades has that
responsibility only a magnify it a
little bit more should get up in the
grades
but uh I you know I'm
I I just I I just don't know how quite
to do this I don't mind putting mental
health in but I I can't do comprehensive
yes right so regretting coach yeah yeah
yeah what you just talked about there
though isn't that what comprehensive
means I mean looking at you know this
isn't my area so the stuff that um
that's been discussed and the the
handouts
um that that came out I think you know
are are very informative
um but when you take a look at at Texas
and you take a look at the New Hampshire
standard from 2003
uh it real it's it it it there there's
there's there's action elements to um to
that like what you were just talking
about happened to your grandson in in
kindergarten but uh but going right
through elementary and middle school and
high school you know it it's not just
mental health education it's not you
know this is what he the the
um the technical definition of ADHD or
the technical definition of of different
mental health disorders I don't think
that's what what what what this is
getting on the the bill sponsor is is
here
um
um and and which feel are you talking
about the the well the um uh 1505 505
yeah okay and and um you know the one
you were just referring to with the word
comprehensive yeah in there but but I I
you know I'm I'm taking that to mean at
least based on on the bill language the
the what you headed out from Texas
Florida as well as the New Hampshire
standards from 2003 that that that that
that that
goes beyond sort of like clinical uh
definitions of mental health conditions
and diagnoses but more of what to look
for what to look for in yourself what to
look for in your friends
um the the self the um what you were
just talking about with your grandson
um you know it comes from within how to
seek help
um you know so it's it's it it's not
self-diagnosis it's not medical school
and I don't know maybe representative
Newell can can shed some light on the
intent of this
okay
well we've got a few hands up right now
representative pedernal and then
representative Tanner
go ahead we've had other pieces of
legislation come across our desks if you
will that um
the argument has been that
adding curriculum to our legislation
adds a burden to teachers and we've been
told that we should trust teachers so I
would argue that we should keep the
legislation on the simpler side where it
already is without adding
either of these bills to the rsas and
that we should trust the teachers that
they are acting within the guidelines
and teaching within the guidelines of
what they've been told to do and what
they think is right
if we do as you're saying does should we
then communicate with the state board
when they come in here with 306 saying
are you going to strip it out of
the ed306 rules if you're going to strip
it out at 306 rules
and they have that ability to do that
certainly then if we feel that this
should be taught then why wouldn't we
stick it in statute it should stay in
the room it should be it could be more
clearly defined in the rules that's what
they're for right if they're willing to
do that
representative Tanner
um
as I look at this
um and I'm thinking what if what if this
bill came through and it said
comprehensive physical education or
comprehensive hygiene
and it it doesn't make kind of sense to
me so
um I know that
comprehensive means all-encompassing and
certainly uh representative cascadden
has talked about how mental health
really has to be a Continuum of not only
education but Services
I think that if we took comprehensive
out of there that I certainly could
support this bill to to have mental
health education simply because
um it's drawing attention to that issue
that's so critical right now
um that's why AIDS was put in there AIDS
was put in there because in
2003 when this was developed it was the
leading cause of death
um
and thankfully it isn't now
um so
I as I said I would I would go with this
bill taking comprehensive tend to agree
with you representative Tanner you know
you teach physical education
um but you know I could also take
Devil's Advocate and go the other side
and say look at ad306 it talks about
comprehensive guidance and counseling
service or yeah a comprehensive guidance
and counseling program
you could just say a guidance and
counseling program probably get the same
thing you know comprehensive is
Define it for me
we're getting close to representative
Damon
thank you
um so two things
I really think it is very important that
we specify Mental Health
when you simply say health it is not
commonly perceived to go beyond physical
health and we've had that come up in
committee on other bills
and I have remarked as I have in many
circumstances over the years I wish that
Mental Health
or automatically included in the
umbrella under health
because the brains an organ and the
hearts and organ and it's all connected
why do we distinguish between conditions
that affect the mind versus the rest of
the body but we do as a society
distinguish that all the time in all
kinds of contexts so I don't think if we
leave it as health that we are being
adequate at all to our students I think
we need to say Mental Health
separately but related
I feel a responsibility to the many
people that I know
personally and professionally over the
years who have experienced mental
illness
and I would
request that we not call these
conditions the malady du jour I think it
makes light of things that are very
challenging for people to deal with
and I needed to say that thank you well
I think by that last comment we're there
are a lot of elements or components
underneath health and that was the
reference to all those components so
um if they're going to Define it and
have it in rules I'm good with it being
there but if they don't I'm good with
putting mental health in studies
not comprehensive middle Mental Health
well we're right now at five after 12
and we do have another one starting at
one o'clock but I think we're a little
closer of understanding what we've got
here in front of us the the third bill
which we really didn't talk a lot talks
about putting this into adequacy
and I think that's
that's really
dangerous
I think it needs to be if it's going to
be in a statute it has to be somewhere
else in statute
like studies
any further comments for today on this
one so we will meet again in October
what was the date
um
uh October 12th right October 12th so
yeah so if you have something that you
you'd like to see the bill tweaked a
little bit come in with some bullet
points or something such as that which
we might be able to look at at the next
meeting remember we have to make this
decision by November
reporting on any well no as a
subcommittee
we could vote any time to make a
recommendation
to the education committee we are at the
committee of the whole right now
even though we're the same people
yeah okay
okay represent Damon
I just wondered if in the scheduling was
it noted that Friday the 6th is the
Friday of Columbus Day weekend
and whether that is relevant to other
folks or not I think there's
competing priorities for some
all right representative it's also a no
school day uh for many many schools
because of professional development
that's the day of the Nea instructional
conference I believe
yep on that Friday the 6th it's a day of
the instructional conference so a lot of
kids aren't in school that day
thought
the 10th is the sixth is October 6th
is that a Friday
well we could move that to the fifth
we could move them all to the fifth
thank you very much appreciate it okay
that's good that's good input
you're welcome
[Music]
you know talking about Columbus Day
up in the district where my kids are
going to school one school doesn't
recognize it as Columbus Day it's
indigenous day the other the school
district itself and another school
recognizes it as Columbus Day so
internally within the district they
can't even get their act together
so um
it'd be October 5th all those scheduled
for the six are now the October 5th good
job
yeah I put myself on it
but you know if on the subcommittee if
you're not going to be there you can
tell Mel put somebody else on there on
subcommittee he can do that
yeah we're all done we're all done thank
you